facebook shields millions of vip users
from standard moderation protocols
facebook is using this program that
white lists millions of vip users from
the company's standard content
moderation practices according to wall
street journal every day facebook users
can have their content taken down
immediately
if the company's artificial intelligence
technologies or contracted content
moderators find their post to be
violation of the company's
rules users in the x check program
however may have their content stay live
on facebook services before being routed
into a separate moderation system that
process is also staffed by better
trained content moderators who are
full-time employees according to the
report wall street journal said that
there were 5.8 million
vip
facebook users and users in 2020 pretty
interesting to think it's not a small
number by the way
5.8 million vip users in 2020. i wonder
how many of them are businesses because
so like for redcon1 we are whitelisted
to post uh ads so we can post an ad with
uh
limited moderation instead of being uh
an algorithm it's a person that checks
it off yeah so we have a level of so i
don't know if that's if it's a companies
or just individuals but for companies if
you do enough business with facebook and
you never broke any rules then they give
you a little bit more leeway
because like for us if we have a
thousand ads that are launching all at
once and it's time sensitive and it
doesn't get approved in time it can
cause problems you can they can we
cannot spend more money on facebook
that's really what they're concerned
with you know does that bother you yeah
tell me why that bothers you well first
of all this is just more of what i was
talking about earlier it's it's the
aristocracy versus the plebeians it's
just it's rules for thee but not for me
you my servant has to wear a mask
i would want to know i actually would
want to know what that criteria is
for example if
if uh uh do they use a trend like this
account
i can be specific i can be absolutely
specific i told you and you know this
for the people that don't know out there
i had a pretty active facebook account i
was getting millions of views
i could count on between three and five
grand every month off my facebook
account and then i made a post uh
correlating the the
pandemic to the wuhan lab and the next
morning i woke up my page was
demonetized restricted and i couldn't
post for 30 days my monetization is
still not back to this day
meanwhile jon stewart goes on colbert
four months later says the exact same
thing i said and he gets applauded oh
look at the the the intelligence of john
stewart the bravery
i'm sitting here i go live on facebook
i'm like are you serious can i can i get
a fact check on this look uh donald
trump you know the pr former president
is not allowed but the taliban leaders
are allowed yeah they're they're okay
exactly
among among them
is soccer star neymar 5.8 million in
2019 he posted new photos of a woman who
had accused him of rape to his facebook
account according to the report
this type of content would have
typically been removed but xcheck
protected neymar's account and blocked
facebook's moderators from taking it
down right away ultimately 56 million
facebook and instagram users saw
neymar's content according to the report
wow okay so this is
that's pretty crazy to think about i'm
just curious enough if there is a way to
get access to that 5.8 million vip
because if they can come up with a
number with 5.8 million that means
there's a way to find out who is on that
vip list and is there enough they know
he's on it and they know there's an ex
check system so somebody knows something
yeah
so so it's probably it's so embarrassing
for facebook it is embarrassing for that
to come out there's nothing that can
embarrass them there's nothing that can
embarrass facebook they get caught
reading your messages they don't care
they get caught silencing opposition
they don't care their fact checking is
an absolute joke it's a little joke by
the way fyi as much as we trash facebook
liberals cannot stand facebook just so
you know they cannot stand facebook they
cannot stand zuckerberg like he's one of
the most hated guys on their side
because in their eyes just so you know
they think
trump won with the help of facebook so
so there is in 2016 he won because of
facebook that's what the social dilemma
or what was the documentary that they
that they made about the uh yeah you
know it was the social
hillary clinton being the worst least
likeable candidate of all time it's
amazing that the steps that they'll go
to you have two choices for president
hillary clinton or joe biden yeah
democrats didn't even choose hillary
clinton you have a choice between
hillary
i hear you but democrats
she rigged her own primary guy you know
you know why because i think at least
the the enemy would fear her a little
bit yeah because there's a part of her
that she you know she's got a track
record of you know people disappearing
so there's there's an element she's way
scarier you do realize you're asking
like the difference between gonorrhea
and like aids all right like yeah i'd
rather go i would rather no i actually
think it's the difference between
somebody
not being feared and somebody being
feared there's a big difference
yesterday i had uh
i had a guy on david what was the name
of the guest we had on yesterday we we
ended up doing it right on time uh the
interview do you know who i'm talking
about i know exactly we're talking about
i don't want to mispronounce his name
but it is
somebody get kai back here what do we do
say
i think you're actually saying it right
you know what i'm impressed okay thanks
i was not expecting you to get this
right out of here yeah so adatia
raj kaul who is the guy that's been
talking speaking on what's going on with
afghanistan the entire time we had a
conversation about what's going on he's
over there he spent the most time
talking about what's going on there he
represents cnn news of india
and we talked a lot about afghanistan
and one of the comparisons i made you
know he said this is trump's fault this
is biden's fault this is both of their
fault this is bush's fault obama's fault
anybody that's been a president the last
20 years fair you know which is fair
absolutely which is fair and then i met
made the comparison and he says listen
i'm a guy that voted for biden i thought
biden would have been the right person
to handle this situation with uh
afghanistan
and then i said do you see the
comparison between what he did and what
uh carter did when it comes down to
presidency you cannot have a guy like
that being number one biden may be a
good number two or three or four or five
or six but not a good number one and
then he turns around and says look at
this point of the game i have to agree
with you you're right i've changed my
position i don't think he's the right
guy for the job and i asked him who
would have been a better hillary or him
he said hillary he said the same thing
as well well hey even our lord and
savior barack obama once said uh
never underestimate biden's ability to f
it up so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]